we are less than two weeks away from the
Super Bowl and Atlanta is pretty much
sold out it is going to be awesome if
you still want it to come send us an
email Sims and left go gmail.com we'll
see we get really almost sold out you
say they're not free that's no BS like
we're pretty much out of seats and I
hear that we have a DJ come we do our
boy rod Simba hit me up today he's
coming down and sow a party yep what's a
party pretty sure didn't Dennis Rodman
talked to rod Simba yeah I don't know
exactly what it was but I think rod is
doing some big-time music producer Kim
jong-eun but didn't he send them the
citizen left go music and go I gotta get
the exact story before I before I share
it but we might have to keep Dan Tana's
open after hours for the rod Simba DJ
session daddy cigars other thing is like
Brad Simba gets VIP seating of course
like he gets a premier front row seat
but I think you agree of course right
before his wedding babe I mean I need
Bill Belichick sitting at our table the
seating chart yeah right I mean all two
weeks of my wedding do you think Bill
Belichick goes to weddings yes you're
right I don't know that for a fact
I don't know wondering yeah hey Bill me
my wife my friends they were kind of
hoping I don't know I just see them
being a quick no but we're you're a big
offseason shirts bring the energy yell
at Sims we're also gonna do q and A's
pretty much every night so don't don't
tell me you didn't have time to think of
one I'm telling you right now if you're
going think of some funny questions of
all questions get on the porch daddy
cigars stimulate your brain exactly and
don't do this part we still got to talk
about the schedule okay oh oh happy
birthday to our second favorite coach in
the NFL Sean McVeigh tomorrow when this
comes out yes on Wednesday is his
birthday Wow and if he wins the Super
Bowl he will be the youngest to ever win
so what is he 33 or 34 I think he's
turning 30
three that is a convertible it's really
making me feel self-conscious as a 32
year old that will be 33 in May yeah me
versus Sean McVeigh's kicking my ass
so McVeigh is 32 turning 33 on tomorrow
January 24th Belichick is 66 turning 67
in April May or April and Tomlin is them
getting this off of Reddit Tomlin is the
youngest head coach to everyone a super
bowl at 36 years old Tom Coughlin is the
oldest at 65 Wow so Harrell if Pete
Carroll would have won a few years ago
he would have been the oldest and now if
Belichick wins Hobie they'll be the
oldest so it's either the youngest to
the oldest were hitting new soul Tom was
65 you said Coughlin yes he was and
Belichick how old right now
66 Carroll's 92 that's amazing to be
able to jump around and chew gum like he
does at 92 what were you gonna say
that's that's him in the coaching world
though what do you mean he's like he's
John McVay of Google reports of Google
darshan McVeigh of Google reports yeah
our social media companies all over the
place trying to find their Josh venture
there Sean McVeigh of Google reports if
josh pendrick is Sean McVeigh than I am
Darrell Bevell
Wow let's do some quail you're not
you're above that now I would Bruce
Arians
I forgot to tell you today but we can
just do this now I watched the fire
festival documentary last night which
one Netflix
yeah mind blowing now watch the Hulu I
will because I watch that no it's not
better okay it's so you have no idea
what this is
you're fired no I feel like I know I do
to this but I don't really know now
there was a festival supposedly going to
be put on that involved I can't believe
her going into this some of the biggest
social media stars all these influencers
on one day all instagrammed an orange
flame going back to the fire festival
that was gonna be put on partially by ja
Rule it was gonna have the biggest
musicians on remember and keep going
down in a little island in the Bahamas
right meanwhile they announced they were
doing it in February and tried to throw
it in April and everyone said no and the
main guy the whole time was going
no we're gonna do it we're gonna do it
which reminds me of so many people that
I've met my life right and they took in
millions and millions and it was all
fraud people that actually went there it
was like hurricane FEMA tents right
thing crap I remember all this now but
it was it was just these guys and
they're constantly frauding like even
when they got caught they were trying to
fraud in other ways to then pay for that
it was just a non-stop cycle but the
Hulu one is gets more into who he is the
Ryan guy what's his name
Billy McFarlane Billy McFarlane that
total scumbag my girlfriend goes into
her emails and goes I have four emails
from Billy McFarlane she was getting
those social New Yorker try him trying
to get them to come and all that stuff
how do these people live with themselves
that's the number one thing that my
girlfriend said right after how horrible
of that yeah it's amazing
do you know why because if you can lie
to the person in the mirror you can lie
to any that's that's oh you're exactly
right when we get to the game film later
some of these coaches were lying to you
the transition King oh yeah so quick
news and notes because some things did
happen before Darrell Bevell to the
Lions yeah that's my take that's the way
I feel about it - yes I am I mean what
are we doing what are we doing a Matt
Stafford I didn't know I mean it's it's
certainly not upgrade I think the only
thing that matters is probably looking
at there is going well Darrell Bevell
will run the football used to do that in
2012-2013 that feels like a plus B I
agree now hopefully Darrell bevels learn
some things I mean I know he was down in
Atlanta helping out here and there but
yes that is the definite underwhelming
offensive hire for me for Matt Stafford
for a guy who I've going please somebody
help this guy okay and they're finally
even though he took a step back this
year I feel like they're on the
direction finally of helping him with a
runnable action often right doing that
stuff but I'm just not so sure this guy
is the most creative guy I've ever seen
in whatever six months for Stafford
trato and hate they hire bevel yeah
Chiefs fire Bob Sutton right and you'll
hear in our film review later why there
are Rex Ryan rumors but I'm seeing right
now that Steve spagnolo is the favorite
okay read and spagnolo worked too
in Philadelphia they have the same agent
they know each other so those things
line up yeah not the biggest fan of
spagnolo no I I haven't seen in the last
few years any of his defense I just I
just see unceremonious firings of Steve
spagnolo and the defense doesn't click
it's a little bit it honestly it's it
can be Bob Sutton Isha's defense for you
you can go well there's some creative
things I like it but they never seem to
be sound when they do it or they do this
wrong I mean hey what is a spec know
they have the year well it's it's uh I
would say Spagnola defense would be
haven't I really described it
he is a multiple defensive guy who
certainly agrees with pressure and
trying to confuse the quarterback but
within doing that a lot of the times he
confuses himself in his own team I guess
that's what was a very unsound right
like you know hey two years ago they
created remember three years ago they
created a lot of plays the Giants I
think the defense was number two in full
and then column
yeah interceptions but then the next
year teams had a chance to study it
figure out the Blitz as he likes and the
crazy coverages and all of a sudden they
get exposed and they're not the same
unit so I don't you have liked Rex Ryan
in Kansas like I'm all for Rex Ryan
first of all I would laugh - when I
heard well Bob Sutton it would be the
same defensive language right Bob Sutton
came from Rex Ryan so you're gonna have
that is it are we gonna get Rex Ryan
Jets and before are we gonna get jet Rex
Ryan who went to Buffalo and just played
one coverage the whole time he was there
I was like I'm the head coach and we're
playing man him being the DC though I
know hopefully he could go back into
that role of being a special special
coach I know that's that's what they had
to figure it's just guys it's really
hard to be in the media for two years or
however long he's been and then go back
because it's a different lifestyle you
begin to talk to other former players
you're like man member we did that that
was crazy it's like a former life I know
to ramp it back up with a team that can
go to the Super Bowl in the next two
three years yeah I don't know I know but
it's in these guys DNA to be like that
too
I mean he's brought yeah a lot of times
the coaches are like damn I mean I'm
just doing TV once a week whether how am
I supposed to do the other six days of
the week they're psychos that's why
their NFL head coaches for the most part
and when he was on his game I'll get to
you in a second he was really a special
defensive coordinator I mean special
like I know you know did things to where
you know again I'll break it down to the
New England seven years I was there in
New England we were facing them though I
mean he was one of those games where I
had to go downstairs and go I don't know
what this coverage is like we got talked
through this I got about 25 place here
where I've broken them down and I got
everything else broken down but there's
like 25 players here where I don't know
what the hell this coverage is and what
they're trying to do yeah I mean that's
that dusty we've always wanted Rex to
just be a decent really do you think
that Rex has been paying close enough
attention and watching enough film based
on what you've seen on TV or have heard
about him that he could jump right back
in or is he gonna be behind the times
when he gets in you hate that question
no I just I think about Rex Ryan like
watching film and I don't think just
from what I've seen from watching SPN
going now this doesn't make sense
yeah I mean he makes you know he listen
he's an NFL head coach and he has
knowledge to share but I has not come
off to me the going oh man Rex is all
over this matchup yep and damn he broke
down this team's tendencies you're
really good let me tune in next week you
know that has not happened yeah it's the
lowest Riddick's it's the other guys
where I go oh okay yeah pay attention
Larry Fitzgerald back on a one-year deal
he gets to keep making runs at some some
all-time records he's up there pretty
crazy
the carson wentz now I just want to
speak on this a lot of a lot of the team
have come forward and this is a funny
thing about this the story was that six
guys came forward right okay yeah so
there's 47 guys that can come forward a
lot of guys are supposed to come forward
I'm just saying where there's smoke
there's fire in every in every lie
there's a little bit of truth is this
story as the whole team think he's
selfish and egotistical no of course not
do I think he's like that no but do I
think that there's a faction of the team
that some of this stuff is probably a
little bit true yeah absolutely
so right now if you're a website in
Philadelphia I would have a public chart
and it would say who's come out and
defended Carson Wentz who are the
remaining players and I'm boiling down
that six just come out I no fighter here
and Jason Kelsey has come out Malcolm
Jenkins has come out right al Sean
Jeffrey has not
there you go yeah right hey listen just
sayin I mean I've your I think my take
is exactly like yours and just to add
some depth to it again what a lot of
these problems I hear again these aren't
carson wentz problems right these are
these are issues the Philadelphia Eagles
organizations have in culture giving him
too much leeway or kissing his ass too
much as a top-five Tropic which was what
oops sorry I totally was that was full
so much liquid that desert you deserve
it was a toss of rice no it was straight
when I was younger we drove home we'd
call that a Gleek a Gleek yeah like when
you're talking like man that was a good
one
sorry geez you're sick anyways but
anyways um my point was oh that's a
Philadelphia Eagles problem right
they've let Carson Wentz be empowered
here to where he's not accountable and
that's what happens in the locker room
sometimes when you are like that and you
don't hold your top 10 picks accountable
the team starts to look at it and go oh
he can do whatever he wants he's a he's
a top 10 pick so I'm listening to
Michael and Barney's book right and he's
talking about Jim Mora jr. in Atlanta
yeah and Deion - yeah who's our guy
DeAngelo Hall DeAngelo hi they show up
to go on a bus to a bowling trip and
DeAngelo Hall has a Bentley delivered
that same day not only did Jim Mora jr.
not make sure he got on the bus he
hopped in the passenger seat are you
kidding me and six months later he was
gone so they shout out to Mike
Lombardo's a little thing yeah little
things like this little things like that
that go a long way the team sees that
and then as soon as the Angelo hall
blows the coverage there's a few guys in
the back of the meeting room they go he
was a little right ya know but the thing
is is Carson Carson is a religious
person he is a he's a a very kind person
he has a food truck feeding the homeless
we've witnessed his wedding Carson is
not the diva and thus these stories
don't seem like they applied to him but
in a football world diva is not always
the loud outs I mean I'm an ego yeah you
know we always hear about Belichick
being able to yell at Brady yeah that's
where apparently I've
this is good for the Eagles I really do
I think it's great for the there is an
issue there Carson Wentz is hopefully
going to self-evaluate
and start to think about oh you know me
maybe saying I don't want to run these
plays because Nick Foles does it more
I'm more advanced than he exactly you
know he's analyzing damn well they were
winning the other way another reason I
love to change yeah other reason I love
yes this is the elephant in the room
yeah and we're dealing with it in
February right this could have been an
entire offseason of going it's out on
the table now
now all the best players have come out
and said whence is our guy whence is our
guy we're handling this in February now
he gets all offseason to talk to them
more because if this would have gone
into September October yeah it would
have been worse um Laser used in Brady's
face did you see it on film at all you
know what I did not and I wasn't
specifically looking for it I wish I
probably looked to wear it a little
harder I think it's a story it is a
story of course I mean first of all
there's not a difficult people in the
Kansas City fan base I saw those don'ts
ice balls of people the week before okay
through a beer can after the game they
tried to throw an ice ball at me or
Rodney Harrison's head I know that but
yeah come on I mean we've seen this
happen in football
whether it was Brock Osweiler in Mexico
City a few years ago right there's been
little issues like that but that's
that's [ __ ] and that's where you
know NFL again to me this is an issue
with them where I would go in like spend
the extra $100,000 a year and have
people that watch the crowd more so we
stop people with fake whistles at a
football game so we stop people who are
just twenty yards up and they're
throwing ice balls at people's heads cuz
we've seen coaches get knocked out and
on the sidelines before at a Giants game
I can remember as a kid it happened so
you know you have security there to
monitor those rows to see if a laser is
going up whatever it may be that's just
the things I think about I'm gonna go to
reddit really quick and I'm just gonna
read a bunch of the ones that I find
interesting I just want to shout out to
everybody on the reddit NFL thread it
really is incredible these the stories
that go in there compared to like other
websites there's some
much better so here's one on Sunday Tom
Brady completed his record extending
12th playoff game winning drive
he now has twice as many a second place
Elway with six that's crazy to me
yeah because you know that that's what
Elway was known for for the last 30
years right and he's doubled up yeah
that's crazy it's crazy but Elway never
had the team Tom Brady did if we're
gonna have this conversation right I
mean now way didn't get the chance to go
the first three times we go down the
field I really don't have to do anything
except hand the ball off and throw a
screen and throw to a Gronkowski wide
open over the middle so yes in speaking
of it it is great but I'm just trying to
give some context to that there's been a
lot of greatness around them to help
those situations and it's I'm still I'm
not trying to do anything bad here Tom
Brady wise I'm very sensitive to that
you know it's amazing what they're doing
in to go further than yeah in 12
postseason games right Julian Edelman
has 96 catches for almost twelve hundred
yards insane just their success in the
playoffs together is wild yes I mean
they're playing extra seasons of playoff
football I mean that's what they're
doing Brady's played three or
two-and-a-half extra years of football
just in playoff football I mean that's
that's amazing in itself a lot of people
have been asking me other caecus Edelman
a hall-of-famer right you know that's
been the big thing I've had a lot of
people come up because I don't know Hall
of Famers I don't know the whole Famer
Adam was really good he's not a
hall-of-famer in my eyes I don't look at
it that way because the steroids
that bothers me too definitely but you
know again I don't think he'd be a
hall-of-famer in a lot of places right
where he's in the perfect place that
knows how to who's invented this
position I mean come on this is [ __ ]
New England they invented the slot
receiver Wes Welker they were the first
ones to do this and make their whole
team based around that kind of guy so
Edelman's also been able to do that too
but I think I mean you put a dome in up
in Green Bay where they don't know how
to do those type of rounds and things we
don't ever hear from him to me a Hall of
Fame receiver is a guy you can split out
on the side all game long ago if they
put the best corner on you we expect you
to beat them or they're gonna
double-team you to stop you and it's
gonna open up other people and Edelman
is not that Edelman if he's ever
double-teamed is only this is like
same argument used in Michael Thomas
he's double-teamed because the team that
they're playing knows wow their coaches
design a lot of cool place room in big
situations and we have to stop the coach
who's gonna design this play for him
here not about oh man we have nobody
that can cover Edelman or Michael Thomas
yeah nobody that's just not what the
story is it is it's it's just hard
because you might happens this is five
years after they retire right no one
remembers scheme right all and remember
nine inches we look at the numbers it's
the same reason why I complain about the
Pro Bowl being [ __ ] yeah nobody
cares about the Pro Bowl until we're up
for Hall of Fame and Ty law had seven
but champ had nine but I thought it
doesn't [ __ ] matter yeah it just it's
crazy it's great oh speaking of speaking
of this weekend bigger than the Super
Bowl it has arrived shut up I can find
his and have there is an opportunity
this weekend for the greatest pieces of
social content to be made that this
earth has ever seen there is an
opportunity for us to get video of
something that is better than Super
Bowls combined take the last five put
them together won't be this entertaining
there is something that can happen this
weekend at the Senior Bowl that they're
gonna ruin and they can't Oh Patrick
mahomes is at the Pro Bowl we have asked
for the longest time scrap the game it's
nonsense
they don't tackle I haven't watched more
than 40 seconds of it in the last decade
but you know what I will watch Patrick
mahomes in a throwing challenge line him
up on the end end line how far can you
throw it I don't really care it's gonna
be amazing that seven second clip of the
ball in the air meme it up
Patrick mahomes target practice Patrick
mahomes running
let's do quarterback trick shots let's
do horse
Patrick mahomes gonna roll out to a
sidearm through a tire 60 yards away
alright Brees go for it we can see
Patrick mahomes this is where we can
really see him yeah I want to see him
throwing off against the crossbar from
80
I want him throwing behind the back for
40 I want mahomes to show the first skip
pass bounce it off the turf into
somebody's hands he could do it the best
event of the next two weeks
bigger than Rams Patriots is mahomes at
the Pro Bowl serious what are they doing
the Skills Challenge who knows I don't
know somewhere tomorrow Oh No yeah real
couples this week uh it needs to be
primetime viewing I'll look it up all
yeah this is everything yeah
this is this is a guy that has done
things we've never seen and he's
agreeing to do things I wish they would
bring the quarterback challenge I'm
saying this kind of thing I usually had
it last year where they're throwing
through numbers and they're all right I
just just forget all the other
quarterbacks just let my Holmes do it
five times Thursday 9:00 p.m. so tonight
when the podcast comes out it'll be
tonight what are you guys doing tomorrow
night you want to get together
I'll be watching watch the Skills
Challenge together I'm so down it's so
funny is philip has been asking ever
since Enuma Holmes is gonna be in it
that's been asking what he knew okay
yeah I gotta have a conversation you
gotta have a conversation me stop
stealing my there's everything that
parents do yeah that I find very funny
yeah and I usually call it the
percentile parent right Oh how's your
child no well his hands are 110
percentile okay
Oh how's your kid mmm well he's reading
at a fifth-grade level he said great are
you making this stuff up about Phil I
mean what would me made up I mean am i
making up about the kid who goes out and
talks to himself and jerseys out in the
Jeremy how much video just say like he
had the wherewithal to go Patrick Holmes
didn't make the Super Bowl we might be
able to see the three C's he's in the
probe or he's talked about it right so
he gots to go there city attention
youtubing crap that's where he gets all
his info from so I hope he comes up to
he goes hey Dad I saw some interesting
youtubes
earth might [ __ ] my son okay I knew that
Philip was in the hundredth percentile
for football brain when Chris walked in
over the summer and said that he walked
in on Philip watching why a tittle
highlights yes
that was when I was like what yeah he
will sit there and watch the history of
the Giants I'm only King but Thursday
night 30 M Patrick mahomes why's it
gotta be breeze that you
to go against we could well I'm just the
two guys that got eliminated the
champion I don't even know the
quarterbacks doesn't actually in the Pro
Bowl at this point I don't even know see
here I don't know
I know Amari Cooper Snellen is a DeSean
Watson's in okay
that's worth turning in I'll pull it up
Andy Dalton just kidding but it you
would believe it like how low could I go
in the quarterback name of saying
they're in the Pro Bowl that you would
believe it I - Allen got it okay there's
no cancel yeah I mean I really don't
even know all of them I don't know Ben
is Benna now I thought I heard Ben was
in now
I'm looking it up who cares yeah but
that's to me I'm very excited to watch
yeah I hope they do they hope they have
that little quarterback thing I'm tell
you just scrap the game make all the
wide receivers run the 40 and just do
speed trials let's find out who the
fastest wide receiver is running backs
like let's let's put up a censor where
you're running to it and we see who has
the hardest truck stick quarterbacks
like line up who can throw it the
furthest let's do an accuracy challenge
like let's put an apple on somebody's
head and knock that bad boy off right
cornerbacks like we're gonna we're gonna
test your speed to like blech it just
forget the game just make these guys
race against each other and then do the
bench press in the middle of the field
like they used to it Larry and I used to
love that stuff man back in the day when
it was John Green running in the 60 yard
sprint most fastest man I was tuning in
on a Saturday they should have the Pro
Bowl in Indianapolis and it should just
be the combine four four four NFL player
stars just do the just do the combines
so the quarterbacks are mahomes Andrew
Luck and deshaun Watson okay for the AFC
and then for the NFC Russell Wilson
Mitch true Biscay and dak Prescott Wow
like Mitchell true Biscay and dak
Prescott of the Pro Bowl yeah that's
crazy
it's crazy I know that's enough Pro Bowl
talk for me personally yeah me too
alright so we're gonna get into the film
I have a lot of good stuff on the film
but before we get to it we're gonna
start off with Rams Saints it was the
first game Todd Gurley came out and said
he played sorry as hell you loved it
yeah have we gotten any more information
if he was banged up or if he just wasn't
playing I saw quotes from him to say he
was not
and that he was just sorry his health
that's what he was kind of explaining
that right there no I wasn't banged up I
was just sorry as hell and I do I give
him a lot of credit for this day and age
where players always make some sort of
excuse or have some reason he just face
it like a man and said it he did play
like crap whether it was the dropped
interception or the drop third down past
where he ran on the halfback choice and
you could tell that was in his head to a
degree I mean he looked like he was deer
in the headlights a little bit he you
now that I have heard him say that yeah
him stretching on the sidelines yes him
sort of being like yeah right the other
social media little nugget that came out
that was great
Ted Rath the strength and conditioning
coach who my girls Serena Morales with
the Rams does a feature on him all the
time right he's officially the get back
coach of Shawn McVeigh where Shawn
McVeigh is on the sidelines and the
funniest thing is if you see this video
NFL Films did it Rath walks he's just
he's only focused on the referee and the
coach that's his sole mission which is
incredible to be paid for that which is
great he is the strength and
conditioning I know but on the game
could you imagine on game day you're not
really watching the game all you're
doing is watching McVeigh and the ref
but what I thought was so funny it's
almost adorable is that Rath runs up and
like gently grabs his hips and McVeigh
instantly it's just like guide me yeah
like they look like Rose and Jack and
Titanic he's like and the amount of
people that hit us up Sims yes and said
Christie did that for the show thank you
very much everybody thank you thank you
but yes I've seen that it's a lot like
the guy in Clemson the defensive
coordinator why do some coaches need and
others don't well because they're
psychos and they're on the field too
much and usually this strength and
conditioning coach
is kind of that guy right anywhere I was
we talked about my buddy
you know Watterson that's in Tennessee
he was always in control of the sideline
right you weren't gonna mess with him
you knew you were put in charge by the
head coach they're usually really loud
usually really loud and they're usually
freakishly strong too to where you're
like damn I mean I could probably take
them but it's not worth all the energy
he might be able to grab errand
old's arm and actually move on that
right like there are psychos they are
true lifelong meatheads
yeah and that's their job during a game
is to make sure the coach doesn't get
anybody in trouble or the players don't
get in the way of the coaches it's gonna
be one of the two my question about this
was so Ted Rath strength and
conditioning coach during the week he's
the get back coach on Sunday yeah are
there any other positions where they
have like an actual job during the week
but then a totally weird job on Sundays
during the game is anyone else on the
sidelines doing weird stuff that we
don't know that's the quarterback coach
all of a sudden in charge of getting the
tea ready for kickoff right I mean he's
on peeling oranges for orange slices a
time he on our he's healing no no that's
a good question actually I mean the
strength and conditioning coach his
assistant who are all going to be on
charge of the sideline duty for the most
part they're always gonna be over
protect and they're always gonna be all
over hey guys get back guys for the
northwestern guy that didn't wear long
sleeves right I'm trying to think if
there's anything else the answer can be
no no I think it is no I think it is no
of course like equipment guys got all of
a sudden be worried about all this audio
technical stuff during again so I always
think about them because all week
they're worried about our shoulder pads
our laundry and all of a sudden they're
like hey as microphones not working in
the 70,000 seat arena guys like I just
played 70 local jay-z and he wants to
look at the coaching all I do is put the
batteries in the pack right exactly but
that's about it if I have another one
like like the quality assistant guys
yeah I mean backup quarterbacks third
stringer you can be all of a sudden in
charge of writing the plays down to keep
them in order so when the the coaches
watch film tomorrow they know what play
is what wheat so you're telling me when
the third-string quarterback is writing
things down on a clip yes it's not even
for that game it's just to make it
easier to watch film the next day pretty
much it's I thought it was gonna be like
what do we do four plays ago no it's
just more I mean that is - they're gonna
look at things and go back but more or
less it is for the next day the coach to
have that and then the the player to
write the plays even that are penalties
so then you don't get in the film and
you go wait wait this play didn't really
happen
I didn't realize for the next it's four
more times than ah yes and then what
were you doing on game days when you
were the Patriots living in a whole city
making in a hole waiting for everybody
to go watch the game so I could go home
and would you watch the game yeah okay I
wasn't sure if you're like no sickness
most of the times I would be like I
would say about 45 minutes before the
game right and we can like sit in the
stands or like stay at our desk and
watch on TV yeah and I was just like no
I'm going home I was gonna go watch this
and I'd go home and sit on the couch and
watch the game Sims has a bottle in 1942
in his cubicle right kicks his feet up
and we'll call Bill how much would I
have to pay you
yeah to do that job now Oh for a year
365 like if you said Adam I'm sending it
back to Hastings Nebraska there could be
a one-man-band newsroom it would be a
lie
I can't even think of the number now
that's all right it's a look back at
your journey sometimes and you go I did
it and I'm so happy I did it because you
helped me out but I don't know what it
would take for me to go back you know
especially with what I've been able to
accomplish and feel why being a dad and
being around my kids to have to go back
to that to not being a dad basically and
just being a sometimes hello dad
that's where I did it I'm glad I did it
because at least it ended the questions
of if I went into media first I would
always going man should I have gone to
coaching first like I think it would
always eat at me the fact that I did it
I realized it was not the right timing
in my life I don't even think twice
about it anymore all right so what
you're gonna see is as we go over the
film of the two championship games some
of these teams are beings not yet some
of these teams are never gonna be okay
again really what happens is when I look
through Sims as notes especially at this
time of the year we're so focused on the
two games that you went deeper on these
and you've done any games usually I get
a page these I got three page for each
side of the ball right so twelve pages
which means it's gonna be very in-depth
but it makes me so frustrated when I
read your notes because you begin to see
why would you enter that game with that
game plan and we're gonna start off
excuse me Saints offense Rams defense
we're gonna take this slow Sims like
uneasy think of love it
and if we
come across a note that will impact the
Super Bowl I want to focus on that as
well okay sometimes you'll see things
ago who Rams can't do that against the
Patriots right Patriots can't do that
against the Rams right so the Rams came
out and it seemed like their concept was
what we thought they would do yep drop
everyone back in coverage and we're
putting all of the pressure on the front
for exactly right my hands down that's
what they did from get-go they were
gonna go we're gonna make the Rams
execute I mean the Saints execute we're
not gonna let up any deep trick plays no
play-action bombs over our head anything
like that keep everybody in front let
the front Ford do their job in front and
we'll rally and make tackles you said
the Rams defense is insanely fast the
one thing they do really well is closing
at the ball yes so as soon as the ball
gets to an Alvin Kamara yes everyone's
attack attack this is just great it is
their speed jumps off the film when you
first turn it on there certainly were
and are the fastest defendants left in
the playoffs in terms of putting all
that pressure on the front for you said
they actually put suin and Donald
together a lot yes is that no normal for
them I felt like it was more not none of
as normal but I do feel like it was new
and I think they did it for run game
purposes that was where I thought it was
different to against the same against
the Saints because I think they said
okay and the run game
teams are going to double aaron donald
right more times not they're just gonna
go we're gonna trust our guard let's do
some sort of scheme where we know we
have two guys on him so he doesn't split
or Juke out our guard one on one and get
in the backfield and ruin the plan with
soother that guy's going I'm gonna
double-team Donald but then what about
him exactly and that's what happened all
of a sudden now that tight ends going I
got a block to by myself and he was
throwing them around like ragdolls
I'm so happy sues performing it was
really performing at a extraordinary
level I'm just gonna stay on the D line
right now
you wrote also you wrote Rams all over
Saints passing concepts in the first
half only issue has been chimera sue and
Aaron Donald balling out tough day for
Pete Unger and Warford and that Donald
was even more dominant in the film than
he was on TV and you thought he was
dominant on team I did yeah but on film
it was he was definitely in the
backfield
more pushing his guy back into the
backfield more than I gave him credit
for on TV you know even just like oh
he's blocked and he slid off the block
just as the running back was going
through the hole and made the tackle
right like just a lot of plays like that
where I was like ooh I didn't see that
on TV
so that was phenomenal yes if I had one
complaint about the Saints don't go and
oh it we're about to say about chimera
about well I was gonna go and if I had
one thing about their issue with how
they were covering chimera yes I do
think there was a few too many third
downs where they put all their eggs and
do let's keep two guys on Michael Thomas
in the slot cuz we know Sean Peyton's
gonna try to make something work with
him right and they left their running
backs one on one to where you have to
almost figure out times and formations
you want to balance that I think when
you play the Saints speaking of Michael
Thomas held to four catches for 36 yards
if I were to ask you now yeah how did
they do it it sounded like that was
their main focus especially when he was
in the slow and he was in the slot they
knew where Michael Thomas was all game
they were not gonna be beat by Michael
Thomas what I've been called the lucky
route what are the cues you look to see
of the defense talking to each other to
know that Michael Thomas is yeah right
like when the film first cuts on right
there's just a shot of the clock and
then it goes okay the clock and then it
goes to the all 22 and you see the whole
field so you see the guys they're not in
the huddle but they're walking out of
the huddle to their spots and I sit
there and watch the defense right and
just listen you look at their
communication and start to go and you
start seeing safeties point to the
Nickelback and giving them eyes like you
know our eyes are there they're making
some signal with their hand you know so
whatever was on Michael Thomas they were
talking definitely and especially if he
motioned down to where okay now he's
gonna be in the slot he might run a
shallow cross or he's gonna be
stationary in the slot and they're gonna
give him these two-way goes they were
all over that aspect of the game to go
no we're not gonna let him catch a
5-yard shallow cross and then turn up
and break one tackle and make it a game
at gain of 25 they for the most part
other than one play I think it was in
the first quarter where Peters was
man-to-man on Michael Thomas and he ran
the shallow cross and got it maybe about
a 15 yard game and as he's going out of
bounds Peters turns around to yell at
his linebacker if you remember this he
just stood there he was way he's gonna
know you
and he said on the broadcast it was
perfect coverage by weight he had the
linebacker exactly where it was and he
was like spying Bri he was looking at
Brees in a third nine like where you're
just like Brees is not gonna run force
was the only time I was the only time
all game they lost a little like track
of where he is
in terms of the Rams they were focused
on the man so much you said they missed
a number of interceptions may as they
just had no awareness obviously
including the non called via the non
call P I the the other one that they
could have called a PI on the drive
before where you know I know the Saints
fans are complaining cuz nickel Roby
Coleman excuse me as I'm burping was all
over the slot guy right and it was
handsy didn't you know again I say this
the fans out there first of all like a
defensive player is entitled to the spot
he's in right so just because a receiver
runs into him and puts his hands on the
defensive back and now the defensive
backs reacts because of that that's
really offensive pass interference the
defense had every right to be there
there's no like oh you're on the offense
you get a free path here and we get to
move out of your way you know I just
want to say that because I do think some
people sometimes people confuse that if
the offense is initiating the contact
and then it's really them at fault and I
have no problem with a no call but yes
there was a few plays whether it was
that play at the pass interference that
was blatantly wrong whether it was the
third down the series before where yes
there was some contact if Nicole Robbie
Coman just looks he's in intercepted
there was another throw in the flat one
time where they did have Kamara kind of
doubled and I thought Marcus Peters
could have jumped it but he chickened
out a little bit and he could have
picked it and then of course the Lamacq
LaMarcus Joyner fade before the MIS pass
interference I mean that was a bad throw
in a bad decision and LaMarcus Joyner to
decide to like go behind the receiver
and wait for it to fall Monroe euro
that's why you can't be paid as a high
price safety because you make mistakes
that that's I mean you're being paid
that money to make those plays right
there to end a team season they've the
coaching staff has put a what we're
calling an elite player in an elite
position to and make a play and he does
the opposite doesn't even break it up
but let's the other team make the play
alright so on the P I yeah you said
the down judge 13 was reaching for the
flag he was reaching his hand I mean we
could watch it together here too if you
wanted to but he is he is literally
cease the contact hand goes like oh I'm
gonna pull it out and then the last
second just pulls away and decides not
to do anything and of course you can see
the reaction in the Saints sidelines
everybody really complained except for
Tommy Lee Lewis which I thought was
funny he was just kind of got okay I got
up and just said whatever he didn't
argue it or anything but you know yeah
hey listen that was pass interference
there's no other way to say it I'm
really sorry for Saints fans that that's
the way your season has to end because
it is a crappy way but the game is more
than just one play I do want to remind
everybody of that there were two plays
of Brees that stood out from your notes
one was the they're they're up 22 17
it's third and 17 and you you guys have
probably remember the highlight when he
throws it across the middle and you kind
of see two wide receivers take in and
they both their eyes get wide and they
realized the balls behind him you wrote
in your notes that Brees had him wide
open yeah and that he missed him by five
feet and you wrote other than the
running back throws to Chimera Brees
hasn't made a good throw all day and
then on the interception he was looking
for Michael Thomas and you were shocked
by two things one he was all the
coverage was all over it was it was
gonna be dicey decision no matter even
if the pocket was clean but also with
Dante Fowler being that close to his
face you couldn't believe it just seems
like you didn't think Brees had a great
day no Brees did not have a girl you
know I think overall my Brees I thought
struggled down the stretch I thought his
aides showed a little bit not saying
they still can't win games but I would
just go I would question anybody there
to go just any Saints fan or anybody
just go you know go back in your mental
you know brain and think about when down
the stretch of the season did you see
Drew Brees make like jaw-dropping plays
or draw dropping throws again he can
execute the offense but when there's
nothing there in the offense he's at the
age where he's not going to make it
happen
himself but yes to that play that was
that was the most shocking thing because
for a guy that has played as long as he
has right it was just amazing to me that
he thought he still could get that off
that's where I just wanted to go like
Tim come on drew you know you that was
too tight like in that moment just take
the sack or whatever but
it's like at the last second he thought
oh let me just put it up high in a safe
spot for Michael Thomas I'll be able to
get it out before Dante Fowler gets
there and it was too late and of course
he didn't even get to finish his motion
or anything so there were two things
that you wrote down then I believe I
don't want to stop we sound like it drew
brees Haider every sounding like that
Josh no I mean your thoughts on drew
brees at this point the season are
pretty well documented I'm with two
touchdowns one interception he played
really well and the thing that it seemed
like the Saints focused on is what I
want to focus in on here for the Rams
defense looking forward to the Patriots
the first thing you wrote down was same
as the first game the Rams took way too
long to line up at the line of scrimmage
and get in place with their defense
happen on the pass interference happen
on the pass interference and you wrote
the Patriots will take advantage of this
I can already see it now Tom Brady hurry
up Donald and Sue aren't even in their
stance
LaMarcus Joyner is running around you
wrote that and I went all the Patriots
are gonna go up temple and then the
whole time but the Saints had success
doing that yes definitely had success
still even though the Rams were so much
simpler this time around compared to
last time yes there was just way too
many plays that there was still
communication going on while Drew Brees
his hands were underneath the center's
you know ass okay I mean yes that's just
it's when a quarterback or a coach see
that there's that communication going on
that many times they're gonna call plays
where we go let's just get up to the
line of scrimmage we feel comfortable
about this play no matter what the
defense is let's force our pace on them
so yes when I think in New England of
course they are gonna see that and go
damn if we continue to send an array of
for personnel sets and formations they
do have communication problems out of
the fact which would be I'm gonna add to
another my main concern of this football
game for the Rams defense and this is
something I know that the Patriots will
do they're gonna look at the Rams ago
what's the weakness of their team and
they're gonna go damn there's really no
weakness with the players the starting
11 pretty awesome at all Evan smile
let's tire them out by going hurry
because they know they play 11 guys the
whole game and that's where they don't
have depth they put their only thing
they do at times is bring in 95
Westbrook
tackle just a spell sue every now and
then or they bring a neck you bomb to
take out nickel Roby Coleman because
they go bass but for the most of the
game the Los Angeles Rams are the same
11 players out there 95% of the time and
my history with the studying New England
is when they see things like that they
are going to press the pace issue on
them all game long a lot like they did
in Seattle well or exactly they did the
Seattle Michael Bennett was like like
couldn't breathe at the end they did it
a lot of times last week if you go back
and watch the game you go Brent Brady
can understand there's under the center
just said set hut a lot like you didn't
sit there and like this check play plus
like it's such an advantage for the
offense to run with pace it is very Rams
offense was better with pace you're
exactly right and the big thing is what
does it do it's all about one thing
because New England they play their
course gonna find your strengths and not
let your strengths ruin their game and
then they're gonna find the weakness and
the weaknesses for the Rams their
biggest weakness on defense is lack of
depth and what they'll do like they did
to the Seattle Seahawks and the Super
Bowl xlix they're gonna run plays and
keep the pace not let them talk a lot of
the line of scrimmage and then all of a
sudden the fourth quarter we go where's
that great Seahawks pass-rush where's
that great a Kansas City pass rush well
you know what they're morn the f out
they're worn out - now rushing the
passer they don't have the same
intensity and explosiveness they had in
the first quarter I also want to say
we're not bad-mouthing Brees 11 of his
twenty six receptions went to Alvin
Kamara yeah he has only a hundred and
forty three passing yards
other than Alvin Kamara yeah right so
that was the focus of the Saints yeah
Brees didn't play great the rest of the
game it's okay to say I'm not afraid of
this money right right but Alvin Kamara
took advantage of the Rams so this is
another thing that you wrote that the
Patriots could take advantage of because
James White yeah
Rams are gonna have to rethink how they
want to cover running backs in the
passing game you wrote the Rams had
their defensive ends hit Camaro a lot
and try and message them out to do it a
little yes but the Saints abuse the RAM
with the running back right and the
Patriots have two guys they could do it
with fact they could put cordarrelle
Patterson back there and do it with him
- they could that's where they're gonna
have to be very careful they're gonna
have to have
some personnel and situations whether
it's third and four or less or things
like that where they're gonna have to go
you know what we're not gonna double
edelman here we're gonna double the back
out of the backfield and we're gonna
play in and out coverage with the
linebackers got the back inside and
LaMarcus Joyner plays the outside and
we're gonna make them throw it to
Edelman one-on-one versus Peters or I
keep to leave whatever it may be but yes
they're gonna have to be picky and
choosy about what they do with New
England especially in those situations
where we know they like to throw the
tailback let's go to Rams offense Saints
defense first thing that environment you
wrote too much communication for Rams
early in this environment they need to
use all purpose plays and play with some
tempo this is a McVeigh problem yes
you don't think McVeigh entered this
game with the right philosophy I don't I
think he put too much on himself and his
players and had to realize that yeah it
might have been loud in Week nine when
you went there but this is a different
animals the NFC Championship game it's
gonna be insane people are gonna be
blowing fake whistles and things like
that and these people are gonna be drunk
as hell and so excited for a three
o'clock Eastern game and lathering up
and ready to go - yes there was just too
much communication at the line of
scrimmage unrealistic - where they
couldn't play I mean you know it's hard
think about an offensive lineman right
he's getting up oh okay I got cam Jordan
in front of me okay I know cam likes to
do these moves okay when he was left
right right and I got a worry okay we're
running running 64 zone okay right right
okay oh wait wait hold on wait wait he's
he's talking to me wait wait he's
checking 297 Seattle okay it's 97
Seattle okay I gotta do this and all I
said oh wait they're silent capping well
how much time is on the clock and then
golfers go so there's no continuity
there's just too much at times and
that's why playing at home isn't an
advantage because it takes away some of
those things you can do as an offense
but yes I think there was too much on a
young football team to communicate early
on in the game and like I said on Monday
take some time out so like I was gonna
say you said forth and to mcvade timeout
in first quarter yeah like so there was
a third and seven
where McVeigh I mean golf was doing
exactly what you're saying he's clapping
for three seconds the clocks running out
it's a third and seven call a timeout
it's the first quarter
their composure go tell your young
quarterback hey we think we're gonna get
this on third down let's be ready but I
like this play you like this play yeah
you do okay good
I don't really [ __ ] care if he does
like this play but I just liked him now
he feels like he's got input here you
know talk to your back whatever it is
they're a young football team I would've
liked to see him do that and then on the
fourth down where Brees got them to jump
offsides yes call the timeout come bring
him over go hey this is Sean Payton and
Drew Brees they got nine million tricks
don't jump offsides it's the first thing
we're gonna do here and then watch the
ball watch the ball I then give them
keys about players in my own we vilify
coaches all the time when they use early
timeout no not early no but I'm Sweden a
time on the first and I'll come back to
bite them at the end of the half yeah
I'm just saying like the media like I
get where they go I need to save on my
precious you're right
see first first half timeout so I don't
put that on stretched on you first half
is about not making sure you're still in
the game for the second half okay and
then danger of being out of the game I
have heard this from college basketball
coaches for the three or four years that
I covered my sport right your first half
timeouts use them whenever the hell you
need right get that home crowd out of it
get our guys right because you can lose
the game in the first exactly right you
need to stop that right and then you
just got to make sure you have a few for
the end of game situation right that's
what it is yeah that's right and that's
where I always look at like Jeff Fisher
I always will give him a lot of credit
here the first half the quarterback
could call a timeout but in the second
half nobody calls the timeout except for
me so he would be served in 11 and the
clock was running well screw you offense
should have got the player you said
about 16 we'll use about Jeff Fisher
after a defensive touchdown timeout was
always believes he's great at this stuff
that's where I mean Jeff Fisher to me
again I don't even know how he ended up
here if I fought there but he is the he
would be a perfect GM a perfect
president of football operations guy
that has useful conversations like this
with the head coach and I do think he
has a tremendous eye for talent but I
know I would make him like the assistant
to the regional manager
I don't know how dare you the whole
title game alright so here's a three
notes that you had that are concerns if
you're a Rams fan about Shaun McVeigh's
vaunted offense
rams ran more boots and play-action
passes that I remember but the Saints
are still all over the routes the Saints
defense is winning scheme and the
physical battle the only positive you
really saw was Roger Saffold and then
you really wrote the Rams offense is too
predictable
yeah the Saints are all over the routes
when they're running pressure right I
thought nothing about this Rams offense
would ever be predictable yeah but
apparently it's gotten to that point
well it's the time of the year where
again you look at it I especially and I
know other defensive coaches will do
this as well you start to just look at
the areas they attack forget all the
window dressing and everything about
pull up a heat map and you go there
either attack in the middle right aside
or do you sorry right you'll be in a
spray chart of where the ball goes just
like a three-point shooter and all these
are all the places he likes the kitchen
or a pitcher always takes it high and in
exactly right same type of thing and I
think when you break down the Rams more
times they're not I think you could go
inside I mean Crowell routes right and
then everything in the middle which is
cross deep crosser shallow crossers 12
yards straight edge in cuts they really
attack that part of the field more times
than not Robert Woods over the middle
and later in the game
same type of thing that's the area they
live on the only time they ever really
get outside the numbers at times this
week there's a sweep or maybe the
bootleg where the guy runs a comeback
that way down there but other than that
yes I think it's gonna be very important
for the Rams to self scout themselves
for the New England Patriots when I read
that I thought of the Falcons yeah and
their Super Bowl against the Patriots
because they did self scalp yes and we
were worried they were so predictable on
defense and all that and they came out
and I think it's sometimes an advantage
against Belichick is if you're a little
bit simple in your scheme he's gonna
figure it out where if you just do the
complete opposite you have a chance
early oh that's what you had that's a
great example Atlanta was there one
Atlanta came out and said oh we've run
cover three the entire year right we're
going man and it was like what go man or
we're number three if we're gonna give
it a different disguise and look you'll
have no idea of what we're doing yeah
and yeah
the long game it's almost like the whole
year you have to prepare for the
Patriots to run one offense and then the
Superbowl it's like we're going
flea-flicker we're going draw we're
going screen usually when I run this
play action pass my Z receiver runs a
20-yard crossing route you know this
week we're gonna run that play and he's
gonna fake like he's gonna run the cross
here and he's gonna run to the corner
you have to do all the opposites that's
why the Super Bowl is so great it is
exactly right you also said Josh's high
school nickname in that break down
straight edging cut I don't
scoop oh cool you are scoops the
offensive line coach my high school
nickname me scoop my freshman year
because I always had to scoop coach is
it true that your left guard has an
ankle sprain all right that's cool that
was actually me freshman year really I'm
actually still no Cham Cham Cham Chan
any well but you would run a great
straight edge in guttin yeah alright so
they were all over it you wrote when the
Rams can't run the passing offense isn't
great but then in the second half you
noticed a change the Rams played with
some pace got up ran the plays and you
thought it really caught the Saints by
surprise definitely they stopped doing
all the checking the line of scrimmage
let's just get up there we know the play
we're gonna run and go with it and you
know the defense the more the defense
gets to sit around and sit there and
watch an offense like line up and
communicating they are getting to go
through their mental checklist of this
is what my coach taught me in this
formation they do this they like to do
this in the drop back pass game you
start to throw a pace at them they're
just going on strike left strikes up and
then they're getting ready they have no
time to go through the rolodex of things
they were taught all we can ask and I'm
realizing staffing so against the Saints
who were prepared for it and you know
Bella checks can be prepared for it this
huge advantage by the Rams of getting to
be able to communicate from coach to
quarterback until 15 seconds yeah right
almost seems like it could backfire on
them because if there's one thing
Belichick would do it show you a look
for the first 25 seconds of a play clock
McVeigh audibles and then the Patriots
audible like I can already see that
happening
it's a very good question certainly that
says something I would like if you know
that's what they do then hey guys in 15
seconds just switch the changes
completely change it I would not be
shocked if you saw those type of things
because yes it's not gonna be overly
loud to where mcveigh's going to be able
to communicate God like he does with
Ranma golf so he's gonna be able to stay
on there and like let's stay at the line
of scrimmage huh
and I would bet you that yes old New
England II will have a like you know
dummy call for defense in certain
situations we're gonna show this blitz
but at the 12 second mark we want you to
back out and you know go to a 3-minute
pressure
whatever's called him old New England oh
no England II Oh Billy ball game in the
end though you said third into that
great Goff rollout where he found the
tight end seats were all over that play
everybody was locked up I felt like
somebody slipped which allowed Everett
to get that ball but you said when the
Rams want to run they go to Saffold yeah
the Saints their front four in big
moments just couldn't get the pressure
you didn't think Marcus Davenport was a
hundred percent you know definitely not
but overall what did you think a Goff's
game
I thought golf overall played a pretty
damn good football game I really did I
mean to take into the fact that of
course there was the early game
struggles he didn't buckle there you
know never really lost his composure or
anything like that and then once they
got in a little bit of the flow of the
game I mean he made some difference
making throws like we've talked about
whether it was the fade down the
sidelines to cooks at the end of the
first half
you know the scramble that you talked
about for it to Evert the bootlegs in
overtime where they were ready for the
bootleg and he's getting hit but still
gets it out to the flat to throw it
there those plays were difference making
plays in the football game and yeah I
thought golf played pretty damn good for
all the things that you take into
account especially crowd noise and hey
let's be serious they didn't run the
ball that great either so there wasn't a
lot there to help him I think I got done
your notes yeah and I didn't feel that
confident in the Rams because I just
kept going okay so their offense is a
little predictable at this point of the
season and
their defense is having an issue
covering running backs out of the back
feed are not that deep yeah it it all of
that scared me yeah I hear you because
while Aaron Donald and Sue are really
good Belichick knows how to negate
people like that
yes well always find a way yes you need
other things to come on top so Shawn
McVeigh it sounds like needs to spend
the next two weeks they get their work
really really build something unique I
think so I I do yeah because they're I
don't even on defense yeah they're not
gonna be able to play the same way
they've been playing at least in my
estimation which is basic yeah he's like
man no man a little but for the most
time I would say last few weeks the Rams
lineup for down defense alignment and
play cover three behind it more times
than not you know there was some third
down obvious passing situations like I
told you where they doubled
you know Michael Thomas in the slot but
for the most part it was covered three
or man-to-man here and there
my only other question that I had was
we're gonna get this in the Patriots
notes that your belief for the Patriots
is taking away the middle yeah was there
anything about the Rams taking away
Michael Thomas and the shallow crosses
and the look ease that you think means
philosophically they may be good at
taking away the middle of the Patriots I
do but the first thing I go to right
away suede Philip knows the Patriots
tell me that's a good thing he's I mean
just whether you just look at his last
two matchups in Denver against New
England you're gonna go oh that was
those were pretty good performances so
he definitely has a feel for I think
what New England wants to do attacking
wise the difference though this time
around is New England is not spread them
out throw it 55 times New England
anymore New England come on man
New England ran 94 plays let's get to
the game let's just get to the game
first thing you wrote we'll start off on
that side of the ball the Patriots
offense because I'm telling you right
now the Chiefs offense section is
depressing
okay Sims walked in i was getting makeup
and i said your cheese offense notes are
making me sad did they fail Patrick
so really the reason the Patriots
offense isn't as disappointed we're
gonna go skills challenge tomorrow night
I'm down yeah be good I might bring pew
but the Patriots offense we expect them
to dice up this Chiefs defense they were
the 31st ranked defense the NFL all the
weapons on the Patriots have made sense
I'm gonna read all yours verbatim
first off modern NFL Patriots run 94
plays 48 are run 46 are pass just
sometimes that simple number this is the
modern NFL where it's all spread and
we're talking about Rams cheese 54-51
and they run 94 plays and more than 50%
are runs I mean when does that even
happen in football lately with a good
team where we go away no mate actually I
could probably know like when is the
last time we watched a good team ago
they're actually 52% run and 40 acres
and bass like I don't even know the last
time I heard that storyline and I mean I
mean there we are again I'm just gonna
wax boy it's New England again invent
reinventing the NFL old Billy ball game
who invented you know what these new
passing rules let's spread it out let me
invent Wes Welker at the slot receiver
and screw over the NFL now he's gone
back and said you know I'm gonna go back
to the Vince Lombardi days of 1963 and
just pull guards and run it every
frickin play and see if guys can tackle
and take on blocks that is the
brilliance of him it's always a step
ahead oh oh oh what Gronkowski and Aaron
Hernandez the two tight end sets so
popular in the NFL huh New England was
doing that ten years ago they've already
moved on they're on three fads later now
ketchup rest of the league Oh hurry up
off on spread offense New England
already got that ten years ago with
breaking the record and having Chip
Kelly in on the offseason to tell them
how they code plays so quickly and do
that oh they're running back out of the
backfield in the pass game oh that's
right that's New England's been doing
that for ten years now I mean they
reinvent the sport like every three
years
and now you're gonna see teams start
going oh we're gonna drive the fullback
and we're gonna know tight end start
running the ball by the time they get
caught up no way
that's gonna have changed again and I
just want to go again like their New
England and this is why they've
dominated the 21st century two things I
was watching the game on Sunday and I
thought about last year's draft yeah
Belichick will sometimes show you what
he's going to do if you pay attention
yes right when you take a guard and you
take a running back in the first round
and we yell at the Seahawks for taking a
running back in the first round but we
look at the Patriots he showed you in
the draft he wants to run the football
he drifted a blocking guard who's not
even playing oh by the way the Patriots
are getting a first-round offensive
lineman back for next year it's not even
playing in the Super Bowl he has even
played all year right but they drafted a
guard and a running back he showed you
right then he went to run the football
yes the other thing is I just looked up
it's I I think I got it right Pro
Football Reference yeah I just looked up
since the merger in a single game has
there ever been a team that's run more
than run 848 times or more and passed 46
times or more Patriots are the only team
since the merger that I've ever done
that
they're the only team in them in the NFL
since 1970 who have attempted 48 runs
and attempted 46 passes in the same game
they're the only team I just did it it's
insane this day and age everybody
wanting our receivers gone 72 to 2010
probably no but you talked about all the
things the Patriots have really started
yeah it's it's incredible you to go into
it you go early on it is a clinic on how
to teach the run game to a third down
shotgun and you said Patriots first
drive is why you take the ball first if
you're Andy Reed this is their worst
nightmare worst nightmare and I know
it's something I said last week yeah
this is what I was scared of that oh
yeah we're gonna kick the ball off like
they did the week before to Andrew Luck
in company and then one say hey that was
cool but you have to evaluate the
opponent this week and New England is
famous for starting fast really and this
is the New England Patriots which you
also know your defense is not that good
I can't believe it so they just
completely took the air out of this
Stadium I mean they took the mojo out of
the stadium from get-go and it was a
clinic and run game stuff second drive
another third down shotgun run
conversion who does it they had three
shotgun run conversion in the first two
drives and you said no one else in the
NFL would have the balls to call that
nobody would have the balls in the same
drive let alone two consecutive drives
ago certain for let's pull the guard and
smash him everybody else like oh we got
a drop back and we got a high love the
weak side defender and uh we're in the
other side we're gonna play a game and
pick this guy and hopefully they're all
open and New England's just like now
we've studied all week and you keep
playing these dumb defenses like this on
third down and you know most teams gonna
pass it but we just think if we block
all of you down nobody will be there and
James White will get six yards on fourth
third and fourth soon as that to that
point two things really stuck out to me
one you said the Chiefs just don't
understand some of the slants by the
defensive linemen in the running game
yeah
Pat's our coach - well too hard on the
offensive line and they're way too hard
on the second level guys and you also
said you would have liked to seeing
Chris Jones at nose tackle more yeah
that the Chiefs lack of disguise with
their defense the fact that they just
sat in the same thing when this when the
Patriots went to shotgun they went oh
these are your pass rushers we can run
on them pretty much so the discipline of
the o-line yes and the simplicity of the
Chiefs defense right the Patriots could
go on third and four this is perfect
exactly
oh you're gonna put a double a gap guy
like we've seen you do oh we got a play
for that this week and Tom touches is
your hole and everybody goes oh it's the
old it's the earhole we're gonna screw
them in the earhole play right enemy and
then all of a sudden they they get the
first down but yes the Chiefs in my
opinion they do a little too much with
their defensive line at times you know I
always go back to this right you know
it's just not realistic to ask a guy you
know they were simpler though there were
they simple in comparison to the Texans
but not simple like that much yes right
right there's a few percentages
everywhere right this is like you know
they don't do it every play but they
have certain plays where yeah like the
nose tackle might be shaded to the right
edge of the center but then at the snap
he
tries to go to the other gap over there
and that's great but you know first of
all the interior offensive lineman for
the New England Patriots are very good I
mean he drafted three athletes there and
they're not like Brandon Brooks like you
guys got there you said Jason Andrews
and Tunie are so good at just on the fly
and they're very they are very athletic
that's why they're great at pulling
that's why they're great at screen
blocking and for teams that do stamp
stunt and slant a lot yeah they're
athletic to go oh he's there but oh wait
he's trying to cross my face and go this
way okay I'm I thought I'll just ride
him that way and let him keep going that
way and if he wants to stop in that gap
good luck I'm riding home and I'm 300
pounds and he's gonna go to gaps over
and then it makes it hard in the second
level to left go because then they're
trying to go oh wait he's got to this
gap
let me where we were trying to show like
we were gonna play it real basic now I
got a shuffle over and get to this gap
but holy cow that gaps huge because they
blocked down there and now it's like
twice the sizes it should be
so there was those issues let alone I
thought there was one or two plays where
like guys messed up on which way they
were slanting right the whole defensive
line sightings on the left but one guy
went to the right and all of a sudden
it's like well damn there's a hole that
left coke and run through so sometimes
Josh I think Sims is trying to do some
stand-up comedy in his notes and he
landed this one I thought he goes
Patriots have played five and the best
pass rushers in the NFL in the last two
weeks and none of them even know what
color Brady's eyes are just a good line
by him they shut down Houston Jones and
Ford this week last week it was Ingram
and Bosa right had a good pass rusher
know the color of the quarterbacks eyes
yeah he should know what his breath
smells like I mean that's what he really
shouldn't that level of detail
hey Trebek man Tom's breath stinks like
I'd I want to get back here and hit him
but man he's breaths horrible yeah like
no I mean this is what New England is
just amazing yet here we are I mean five
of the best pass rushers we've seen and
they don't even touch Tom Brady let
alone like knock him down or pressure
him they don't touch him like he comes
away on a grass field and has no grass
stains on his [ __ ] uniform you made I
was gonna say you're making Josh nervous
I know with all the bad breath stuff I
usually [ __ ] jack no thank you but but
it just
what they do once again is aggressive
defenses they go oh you're aggressive
that's one of your strengths well we're
gonna take away your aggressiveness and
when you have to sit there and worry
about the run worry about the run oh oh
wait he's faking the run a plant let me
wrap up and try to pass rush oh it's too
late he's already thrown the ball okay
no they're gonna throw this time I'm
coming off the edge art oh damn it on
third and four they ran inside on me
what I didn't think that was it's just
always that and it's not just throw a
line that can block Edelman and candor
in cordarrelle Patterson you said can
block any linebacker and any safety
that's what makes them so dangerous
because then you go oh they're an 11
personnel here comes three receivers
surely they're gonna pass it they're not
gonna pull a guard on this set and all
of a sudden Tom goes all the safeties
down in the box damn we're a little
outnumbered and he brings one of them in
Cordero comes out comes in and he goes
right between the tackle just a huge
he's a man he's you see more like 230
yes he's ripped and Edelman is fearless
and strong as hell to just put his body
and so they are they are guys that yes
at least we'll put their body on you to
give them the chance and again it just
makes them you know not one-dimensional
now on the Brady interception that was
negated by the D Ford offside yeah you
wrote he thinks the game is over he did
not see that penalty why is he so
herky-jerky he got it was one of the few
times all game he was felt the pressure
of the pass rush a little bit like he
was looking downfield to his right and I
can't remember it was Houston or D Ford
coming to his back edge but they were
coming to his back edge but they were
gonna get pushed by but he could feel
their presence and like without locating
Gronk
he kind of just like went there and
threw it all in one motion he never
really looked at him right he was like
looking downfield and then he just threw
his feet and his body over there and
threw it and get them all in one motion
and he lost control of the ball and yeah
you know me I like to watch what people
do have to buy I mean he truly thought
the game was over Brady started the jog
after the guy after he picked it and
then just sit there and this the
shoulder slumped and the head went down
and he was turning around to walk off
the field and then they realized there
was a flag which was egregiously
offsides egregious
egregious like he was ahead in front of
everybody else how does that happen
I know I know but he was you know I
heard Andy Reed say like usually a guy
gets a warning you get a warning if
you're like an inch off sides okay where
they might go hey you're cutting it
close you need to back up a little bit
if your blade when you're like whole
head is past the football there's no
warning
how is no one else on the defense
telling him to I don't know you're right
nobody sees it but because they're all
down in this position right and they're
all looking at the ball in line and see
no and they can't really tell and they
got their own things to go and yeah I
mean the only guy that might see him is
the other side to pass rusher to go like
hey I could see so far ahead of me right
move back but yeah that was um like I
said on Monday I thought on TV that
Brady might have saw the penalty out of
the flag did not but even before the
snap you know it's just to say I mean
again just so we take any ref
controversy away from this the ref is
sitting there before this with his hand
was yeah he knows the guy's line is it's
nasty 32 exactly right also everyone's
making such a big deal on the big third
down completions in overtime yeah and
you wrote that on the first and second
one they're really busted coverages and
mistakes by the Chiefs they knew they
were in - man
right so - man from man to man
underneath five guys man to man
underneath straight across the board
with two safeties back right so it can
really allow you to play aggressive on
the underneath routes because you have
help behind you and what New England did
was they first had a stack right and the
first one where Edelman caught the post
to Brady's left down the middle they're
supposed to switch it the two defenders
it's stacked one of them's going to take
the first guy outside the others gonna
take the first guy inside fuller messed
up he went with his guy that he was
covering the whole time and they
switched the release so he had to take
Edelman he jumped to his guy and then
tried to get back when it was too late
he was wide open it was the easy
completion for Brady then the next third
and 10 they bid similar play other side
and instead of lining up in the stack
this time they motioned him from out
right and then they went across again he
went underneath - where was a stack
release again but the guy covering him
kind of ran into the guy who was
covering the other guy and also knew
a free completion down the middle and
then on the third third and ten they
said you know what screw this - man look
they've obviously nowhere and they tried
to play just single safety 11 rat right
with one safeties deep another one place
for the middle because they're going
we're not gonna let that on the throat
over the middle we called it robber
robber sure it robber a rat it depends
on what safety it is usually you know
then I had a good defended Matt and I
would play rounders a robber and but
then that play was asking Runk Gronk
slant and you know Eric Berry being
asked something to do that he's not
ready to do at this point of the season
with being injured as long as so not to
make this all positive Patriots on the
Patriots offensive side of the ball you
did give a little game plan on what you
would do to defend them yeah
specifically for the ranch yeah you said
when playing the Patriots you have to
crowd the middle of the field in the
passing game when I read that the first
thing that came to my mind was Rex Ryan
yeah okay that's what Rex used exactly
right Tom Brady all that right just drop
back seven guys both Brady interceptions
came over a crowded middle you said you
would force play actions to show though
the Pats to show that they will
consistently throw outside one on one
mess and if you were the Rams you play
man and man on the outside and flood the
middle with the other play exactly right
defend the race I think I would yeah I
would play
listen you paid this is the this is the
male this is the payoff game my early
breakdown of that would to go this is
the payoff game this is why you've got
to keep till even Marcus Peters this
it's this game right here here it is
because you have an advantage here in
one area specifically in this matchup
where they don't have great receivers
that are gonna scare you deep or do
anything like that and you have big-time
corners so they're gonna have to be
asked to maybe do more than their normal
you know lunch pail of work here okay so
that would be the thing I would do and
then yes I would flood the middle - you
know and again Brady still throws it
awesome and can throw it outside the
numbers but I'm just saying they don't
love to do that you have to take away
something from doing and you have to
start somewhere and I would start with
I'm not gonna let them throw - Edelman
and Gronk over the middle than bi by a
thousand exactly right like you know
what if he can throw 20 yard comebacks
tatelman on Marcus Peters all day then
damn it you deserve the Super Bowl and
go
head butt you're gonna have to do
something out of your comfort zone and
that's one of my plea to the rams would
be it it makes a lot of sense yeah I'd
rather lose to Brady trying to throw
deep than fifty surgery over the middle
like yeah come on eat me deep do
something else you got there got to
because we have better athletes than you
exactly right they're gonna be the more
talented team on the field certainly
where's the money on your team right and
then use it exactly right
your front for your two years right
exactly right there you go thanks for
button on it up there kid are you ready
dad you're inspired by your brother in
the water for today's podcast all right
Chiefs offense Patriots defense what we
always like to see when the Patriots
defense on the field is on the first
play who's guarding who yeah
does Belichick ever like lie on the
first play well you have to get him into
a play it doesn't always necessarily
mean the first play but you got to get
him to play that Thursday play of like
oh this is they have to do this okay
they have to throw its third and long
what's he gonna do to screw them over in
that situation so here is how the
Patriots defended the Chiefs they put JC
Jackson on Travis Kelce we knew that was
gonna be the case they put Gilmore on
Watkins as we've always said about
Belichick I'll take his number one and
he'll eliminate your number two right on
that first play Conley was on the field
they put Jason McCourty the other corner
on Conley and on Tyreke Hill they
doubled him with Devin McCourty
and Jonathan Jones so not even JC
Jackson not even Gilmore Jonathan Jones
and McCourty the guy who could probably
handle the quickness underneath and then
they always had a guy over the top and
then you begin to write and this is
where I begin to cry every play it's the
same coverage the Patriots are up in the
Kansas City receivers faces and the the
Chiefs didn't adjust but you also wrote
down a little too much grabbing from
Gilmore and JC Jackson but this is a
smart move by Belichick the refs don't
want to be the stars of the championship
game they don't want to throw flags in
the first three plays
see you set the tone early you get real
handsy
yeah and now that's the new normal for
the Patriots and you think that they've
been it that's an actual coaching
instruction I think hands early be
physical be handsy you know when in
doubt hold don't get burned on anything
deep early like if you just take the
pants take it whatever right all of that
I think all that comes into play in
their thought process yeah so I'm just
gonna run down all the ones that
frustrated me about the Chiefs inability
to take advantage of the double-team no
dedication to the run game for Kansas
City the offensive line getting whooped
by one defensive tackle and one
defensive end that she's have to have
more man and man beaters for Kelsey and
Tyreke and really what I thought was the
biggest issue you're running Tyreke on a
shallow cross he's dragging two guys
with them means there's no safety deep
why are they not filling that void and
taking advantage of the Patriots showing
their hand and double teaming Tyreke oh
because nobody had played them like this
the whole year
no one double-team tires like they did
but not the way they're matching up with
everybody else not to where they're just
going on a bash double-team like screw
with safety in the middle of the field
you're the greatest arm thrower and deep
ball thrower ever we're gonna do [ __ ]
that you would never think we're gonna
do and we've played you twice the last
two years and we didn't do this in this
match those matchups either so that was
one thing they're just weren't prepared
for it they weren't like gonna go I just
don't think I think they thought okay
there'll be some situations where they
double Tyreke but they're not gonna play
us a man-to-man across-the-board they'll
have somebody deep in the middle of the
field even when they do that but no they
said negative ghostrider that's not
going to fly and yes they played the
same coverage every play until I believe
had no nine in the third quarter they've
dropped back and played three zone one
that was the first time I said damn
that's the first time they have a
man-to-man double tie reading the whole
game and you know why they did it then
because I think the Chiefs had had that
was one put they'd already scored on the
first tried to make it 14-7 and they
were backed up and he was going I know
Andy Reid he might have a feel for my
defense now he's gonna take a shot right
here he's gonna try to go for the
jugular
and he played something safe and
different so they couldn't gameplan some
play on the sidelines for the coverage
were talking about and you said the
Patriots did a good job of containing
mahomes with a late-game greed dog
looping yeah late game yeah so you know
we talked about on Monday how we saw
like the defense ends crash inside right
to almost be the inside rushers and then
the defensive tackles would loop outside
right the end tackle game they would
call that right but what they did to was
their linebacker would come up into the
line of scrimmage and be there to where
the center has to respect him like oh
the center is like oh I'm not sure if
he's blitzing or what but he's kind of
attacking me so I can't go help out my
other guards but then as soon as they
were just paying attention him Holmes
and as soon as the mahomes and the
twister started to go there they would
start to loop around the edge to be that
next guy there just in case he got
outside of the twist that he was gonna
they were gonna be there and not let him
scramble yeah you said the Chiefs didn't
call enough place to back up the
Patriots no safety sometimes no safety
over Sammy and they never push the ball
downfield
I was disappointing other than that one
bomb on third and 2 to Sammy that
exactly which was a scramble play I
wasn't even like again that was a that
wasn't a called shot that was mahomes
getting out of the pocket to the right
which he was not able to do a whole lot
and making an amazing play but yes where
I think that they really messed up more
than anything is of course you know
there's they should have approached
things differently they could have made
life hard if they put all three in a
bunch together you want to play that
coverage where you double-team one guy
and man-to-man the other guys okay try
sorting this out when we criss cross in
a bunch and everything have fun like
running into each other there okay the
other thing you could do of course I
wanted to see more deep shots from a fer
of walkins or a Kelsey take the
aggressive take the no fear that Bella
check and floor has had during the game
to go just get in their face keep
getting in their face like there was
never anything to back them off and they
did in the fourth they did in the fourth
finally they started coming up with some
plays that we're gonna screw over this
coverage and the last thing I think they
really messed up was they put Hill once
they realized after like the second
Drive okay they're double-teaming him
every play you've got to take Hill out
of the slot right you
take him out of the slot because now
that free safety in the middle of the
field who's really doubling he has to
show his hand to get over there
and if you have Kelsey and Watkins in
the slot let's just say running seam
routes there's nobody there I mean they
can literally just ran four verticals
with the hill outside and go double him
but it but by keeping them in the slot
they're in essence keeping the safety in
the middle of the field to where it
doesn't even sometimes you're not even
sure they doubling him here or is he
just cuz he's where he would normally be
exactly right so they never forced them
to show their hand that way you did say
in the fourth quarter the Patriots
changed it up and put JC Jackson on
Sammy and Gilmore on Kelsey which we
were talking before this is what this is
what Rick Pitino used to do when they
won the championship yeah I'm gonna show
you a defense for 25 seconds and at 10
seconds of the shot clock different guys
guarding right and it's you were saying
this before
oh you're used to going up against JC
Jackson and you think he may have a bead
on him and understand his eyes and his
hands and hips right here Stephon
Gilmore in the fourth grade
exactly yeah not like me not
mind-blowing but we switched up the
matchups you were come you were finally
getting comfortable beating JC Jackson
and damn now we put Stephon Gilmore on
you in the biggest moment is that
decided before the game that you're
gonna do that in the fourth quarter or
do you adjust based on how to game no I
think that was a fourth quarter changeup
wrinkle like that they went where he was
like I don't want to reinvent the wheel
here but let's give them something a
little different here just to you know
maze you know layers not feel as
comfortable you don't want to sacrifice
three quarters of not having the matchup
you will know exactly right I think they
felt comfortable with those matchups and
I think they're thinking let's change it
up and I also think they're thinking
it's the fourth quarter they're gonna go
to Kelsey anymore in this situation so
let's put our best guy on him now they
did get the walk-ins deep pick play the
Robinson deep cross you did say they
were able to use swing pass it to
Williams across the for me to get some
real inside right right so you did find
ways to take advantage of them yes but
just too little too late too little too
late too much on number 15 just that's
just it was too it was it was a great
team playing a handful of great players
and the team won and they just asked
number 15 to do too much
on his own where there's Tom Brady and
he was great but he had a lot of help
along the way to be great that was my
saddest thing is we applauded Andy Reid
all year for his formation usage for his
pre-snap motion for the jet sweeps for
moving guys around never letting you get
comfortable making you show your hand
early in the play clock because of all
of our movement and when I looked back
at that game there was none
Tyreke L stayed in the slot they did not
there was not a jet sweep I would have
liked a Tyreke L at running back that
would have messed up the Patriots well
there wasn't a bunch there was an
emotion other and so yeah for you to go
into a game against Belichick and and
rightfully go we have better athletes
but for you to kind of go we're just
gonna beat you nobody does that
that's the saddest thing is that a
season defined of distraction and and
this creativity and in the biggest game
of the year to use none of it it just
felt like a lot just felt like a bad
game by and it's disheartening and you
know again just I I just you know nobody
uses New England's logic on New England
that's where I want to go like you know
how are we talking like it's our job to
show that they can't do this like know
at some point
Kansas City's got to go damn they're
only playing two defensive linemen on
the field and it's like in tre flowers a
defensive tack right it's tre flowers
and one of the Big D tackles and it's
four linebackers or three linebackers
every play and that was their weakness
and if you're going to beat New England
you have to exploit some of the matchups
that you have in your favor Kansas City
you have a good offensive line if they
want to play with three small defensive
ends and a linebacker and only have one
run stopper yeah you got to be willing
to punch him in the face a little bit
more and I felt like you know they
weren't willing to do that no and it
stinks too because you spent all week
and it's it's funny saying that you need
to establish the run has become a very
divisive statement in this current
football climate where some people
believe that rushing attempts aren't
that big of a deal the prowl
mrs. because they kicked the ball off
and because the Patriots had the ball
for like 14 in the first 16 minutes they
probably felt up against it so Damian
Williams getting 10 carries for the game
it was never gonna be enough like one of
the things we said last week right they
had to be round he wanted defense office
exactly exactly right now the one
critique you did have for mahomes
yes there is one yeah he said he has to
get better at stepping up in the pocket
last year yeah I won't hear it well when
he wrote one critique for my homes I was
like oh no what is it there's an
infection and then it's step up in the
pocket I was like that's every young
quarterback ever it is exactly right
it's a young quarterback thing that has
it's the leases and the Brady's that you
watch their feet and you go wow they
step up so part yes and it's because
they don't have the athletic ability to
spin out and run around the edge so
right so they've never had that a that
ability to do that so 7 tempting today
right so they stay within their confines
sure Biscay does the same [ __ ] right
exactly right have you seen DeSean do to
watch Russell Wilson wince right exactly
right it's all those type of guys
because they have gotten away with it
for the most of their life high school
college football whatever it's a lot
easier to tell Fenric to lay up then a
guy that's been dunking it's exactly
right like yeah hey LeBron you do you do
layups just like the white boy protect
your ball and do the layup it's like no
I know what I'm capable of
that's just something you dunk yeah he's
got some calves alright got some calves
but if the rim is around six feet but
he's got to get better at that the game
is still praise Drew Brees his footwork
by the way you just let that totally go
by under this is a great quarterback
I think Drew Brees could play another
season and they could go to the Super
Bowl yeah I really think they have the
team four and all that I'm just messing
with ya it's just um game's got to be
won in the pocket though hasn't changed
yet game's got to be won in the pocket I
haven't I haven't seen a quarterback
going to the Superbowl running around
everywhere and win one yet I haven't
seen it Josh Allen 22 Russ Wilson was
close since Super Bowl 49 there at the N
but other than that the game is won by
the guys who can be precise stay in the
pocket and make big throws from there
and mahomes needs to improve that just a
little bit so my big takeaways for both
of the game from your film study right
the Chiefs defense was too simple
they stayed in the same thing the Chiefs
offense was too simple they didn't do it
but they did have some good plays and
they were able to adjust late in the
game but it was too little too late
the Patriots patience with their running
game is unmatched their use of
formations their ability especially in
this game to isolate and tire out the
other team was all you needed but there
are ways to defend them for the Rams
clogging the middle forcing Brady to
beat you on the outside and making sure
you're able to take away that run gate
if it's possible right from the Rams
Saints perspective the Rams need to not
be predictable in their offense the
entire league now has two years of Shaun
McVeigh and Belichick is gonna go and
watch Shaun McVeigh running routes at
Miami of Ohio to go and see maybe he
likes to call these routes because he
ran these routes so he really needs to
come out offensively and and mix it up
yeah because your zones are taking a
care of now the Rams defense their issue
for the Super Bowl is gonna be how do
you defend running backs out of the
backfield because I think the Eagles
took advantage of that and that win too
when they went to LA and beat them
chimera out of the backfield was an
issue white will be the same way and
just I get done reading your notes it's
gonna be an uphill battle for the Rams
definitely but like I feel like we
already knew that but it just sometimes
the film like we're putting Aaron Donald
at defensive end to be a wrinkle or
where the Patriots go oh we're just
gonna run that way yeah it's gonna be
the the Rams are going to have to find a
few new wrinkles for the game on both
sides of the ball to give New England
something to think about but the Rams
have this to rely on they are the more
talented team I do believe that every
Patriots Super Bowl I feel like you're
right pretty much and they have some
matchups to take away some of the things
that would concern me
like what like we're talking about the
receiver thing once again like hey New
England should not scare anybody with
like Oh with guys that are gonna beat us
deep on post routes or go routes they
shouldn't scare anybody I mean sorry
yeah core Darrell's not really a deep
rapper Dorsett's not really a deep
threat you know Chris
Hogan Edelman so they're gonna have to
take some chances right that would have
been a decade of an issue right so you
might have to take some chances and
coverage to take away some other things
that you might see schematically that
you know give you problems so that's
where I look at from there you know and
again hey listen I worry also about the
Rams receivers against those New England
DB so I'm thinking that's that's that's
troublesome because now they're gonna
jam the hell out of those guys I think
the duo
in New England is better than the duo
with the Rams you think Gilmore and JC
is better than Peterson Talib you gave
me my choice right now I can't even
believe I'm saying it out loud as I'm
saying it but yes I think those two no I
don't think anybody has put under more
pressure on a weekly basis than number
27 and 24 in the Patriots it also scared
me when I read your notes that Sean may
Shawn McVeigh's timeouts were really
that great yeah that he came out and and
wasn't prepared for the communication
issues I learn I know he will
but the Super Bowl is different it is
different even though the championship
game is epic the Super Bowl is gonna be
wild and I'm hard pressed not to think
that this could be a Patriots blowout
oh I mean of course we're hoping that
yeah I don't think so I think there's
too many good coaches on the Rams
football side to be blown out I think
they're too talented I really do you
know how do you think he game plans for
Donald how does he game plan for Donald
well he's not gonna be afraid to trust
his guards every now and then to just go
okay but he's gonna find again that's
one way to plays where he's gonna go
wait this is when I can't let Aaron
download beat Aaron Donnell and what
that situation is I don't know if I
could tell you right now or figure it
out but he's gonna find certain plays or
certain downs and distances where he's
gonna go I don't like this and we have
to do something extra to protect against
that or whatever it may be you know
other thing the last thing about the
tape painters Chiefs game you know what
them one of the most amazing things of
this game is the Patriots Chiefs game
the fact that it was 37 31 I mean you
look at the stat line and you just go
ma'am this one team must have
annihilated the 37:14 the team that ran
had
thirty-six first downs against the team
that had 18 first has a double DOMA 13
for 19 on third down for four nine five
hundred and twenty four yards 290 yards
ninety-four plays forty-seven plays
forty-three minutes of time is Asian 20
I mean all that stuff says like Oh
that'd be a must've been 3114 that's
that it says to me I mean that's I still
am amazed and that's how great Patrick
mahomes is it really is that's what it
does it just shows you how great he is
because he's just like oh well I got to
make five plays and we might be able to
step I think I could make five and he
only made three or four instead of five
it's I would not be surprised of
Patriots Chiefs for the AFC championship
game for the next few years I wouldn't
either at least next year yeah I mean
their offense is that great in Kansas
City that they can overcome a 31st
ranked defense and still almost go to
the Super Bowl
what are we are we doing the mailbag
tomorrow that's up to you guys you tell
me yeah I think we're gonna do a mailbag
so if you hear this and you want to
respond Super Bowl questions anything
shoot us the mailbag just to let you
guys know though we're recording the
mailbag it's gonna come out on Monday so
here is our schedule for next week
we're not obviously doing the betting
show because I don't want to make my
picks a week and a half ahead of time I
mean who the hell knows what's gonna
happen right and you don't want to make
your pick you know about our shows
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday we're
gonna record a mailbag tomorrow that's
gonna come out Monday so that you're not
going a week without hearing from us
during the two weeks of the Super Bowl
so we're gonna put it out on social this
is Wednesday night to get more questions
and all that stuff but also you can hit
us up if you're hearing this in the
morning because we're not gonna be
recording until the afternoon so suit us
whatever questions you want we're gonna
have a male bet that comes out Monday a
Super Bowl mailbag and then you're
getting shows Wednesday Thursday Friday
so are you excited for traveling not
really
I'm going Sunday Monday hopefully we we
beat the the initial rush by going that
early I know
sign up for clear did you get clear yet
no man I did that our last Super Bowl
lifesaver I might need to with these
airports all that's scary
with all these public employees
especially when I hear about how Atlanta
is yeah I know
Atlanta's not good even when the
government's running yeah that's what
I'm worried yeah but I I know that I'm
coming out and saying it could be the
Patriots in a big one man I who knows
the ramps know thirds are too talented
and they got to bright minds on both
sides of the football for us to just go
New England wins good film review Sims
thank you I don't let go or Sims he's
not ami forfend recuit evening everybody
for the lef koe and we will holla holla
holla at you later oh my gosh Atlanta's
gonna be six Sims and left coach emails
not coming